Fabi you have completed the tournament
you've completed the grand chess tour
how do you feel your results have been
throughout the tour itself
it's been a mixed bag but yeah it's a
good way to end it I don't know if this
gives me some slim chance of getting
like third place in the overall Tour
rankings if the results go my way maybe
I'm not exactly sure but um
but yeah today was a good day it was
quite an interesting round I mean it was
one of the bloodiest rounds in uh in the
top tournament I've ever seen you know
um and okay Hans was also uh gone in for
a fight today
well tell us about your
fights where did it go wrong for him it
felt that you got an advantage pretty
early on
well you know the thing is he's he's an
interesting player because he he plays
like extremely uh responsible makes
extremely responsible decisions
um very quickly and I I had a feeling
based purely on intuition
like his decision to play G4 was a
surprise I mean he played it I don't
know within like two minutes I was very
surprised I basically like stepped away
from the board thinking
okay it's a complicated position and now
it's he's going to take a long time and
then the G4 gets splits down and I was
like
um I I was a bit scared by this move but
on the other hand it also felt
extremely risky to me
um
and also I was wondering by the way uh
after like C5 he he played very quickly
but like Knight DB5 was interesting made
to be very disposition that you were
planning what ctex B
M Knight D6
no PC is bad I think Bishop takes E3
because BC is just Knight C8 CD Knight
B6 oh yes and Rook da and I end up down
upon for for very little right so Bishop
E3 instead of BC
okay it's some sort of mess I thought
that it would be
sufficient for black does the line
continue
I guess he puts the queen on D3 and I
move my queen probably to C7 or well see
yeah I don't know maybe but C7 looked
natural
uh
I don't know what this is like 98 rookie
and I mean F4 is falling
I couldn't fully calculate this but
um felt like it should be good for black
he goes bc5 very quickly Queen C5 G4 and
then you took a long time here on your
move Bishop A5 but you've started to
feel that this was too much for for
white well I wasn't sure I didn't think
I was better still or I wasn't sure if I
was better but Bishop A5 felt very
natural
uh the thing is like first I want I was
just wondering G4 H6 and I think I
understood his point which is now if he
plays Bishop F3
Queen C4 he has suddenly G5 and if my
knight moves Bishop D5 everything falls
apart that's what I was thinking at
least uh so then I thought okay let's
let's not keep the tension let's try to
resolve the issues a little bit also I
was getting low on time
and okay I was thinking maybe Knight B3
was a bailout but wasn't 100 sure take
on C3 Knight C5
take take Rook D2 rookie three I'm up a
pawn but
my feeling is somehow White
should be fine because of the pair of
Bishops yeah just somehow I mean also
the my pawns are rather weak so are his
but uh I would be surprised if black is
actually better here okay
and then Queen D3 I think he he missed
this queen before right and after that
he suddenly like just tactically
everything's hanging did you see any
resource for him in this position well
so I was like there's like five
different ways he can try to defend his
Bishop only one works and I was just
tell me which one it is
that's one of the moves I didn't
consider the sixth option you know I was
thinking in Bishop A1 Bishop C1 Queen B3
Queen B1 yeah none of those all sorts I
know that none of them work we're okay
one I I didn't see it all and I guess he
equalizes like that yeah yes uh take
take Queen E4
yeah I mean
I I guess I still it's not like like
entirely without risk here also but it
should be equal right so he plays Rook
B1 you actually took a long time
deciding whether you want to take the
exchange or take the pawn I assume with
Knight C5
yeah yeah 95 I mean there was even like
Rook A2 but I didn't really like it
um yeah Knight C5 but then I know I
spent most of my time calculating id2 I
was just trying to understand this
position okay because he does get a pawn
and didn't seem entirely clear-cut to me
right so Bishop C3 let's go down the
line this check is important of course
to prevent King G3 we went over this on
the broadcast King G1 here yeah I wasn't
sure about Queen A4 also like okay uh I
mean queen C5 is also natural Rook B7
and like
you know like Bishop C6
has a point like Rook C7 Bishop B4 but
but he can take and then Queen D4 I mean
after Bishop C6 ah okay Bishop C6 take
Queen D4 and Knight E5 I wasn't sure
what this is take queen queen B7
take I mean okay I was a bit worried
about this one it's a mess yeah I was
kind of scared uh so this I I was proud
of this Knight Queen H Queen A4 Knight
H4 idea yeah but I was surprised that
he okay Bishop B2 is maybe a good move
but I I was thinking like
the critical move after Knight H4
is um
what's the critical move
uh Queen Bishop B1 Bishop B1 is
extremely critical I thought we're just
kidding A8 this is the point that if
Rook takes D7 Rook G2 King H1 rookie
Rook d2i I win the queen
but after Queen A8 he has this move
Queen to B3 I think yes Bishop C8 Rook
B8
Rook G2 King H1 Queen E4 and this
position was uh because he has moves
here like he has Queen D3
and yeah
and uh I wasn't I think I saw something
here but
I can't remember what it is there is
like some
crazy position almost Knight F3 almost
works
are three
um yeah which is the only move not to
lose foot but sufficient but wait after
Queen D3 what did I see there was some
some move here oh wait don't I have Rook
I'm gonna work F2 I don't have
no why not because you won I get made it
on the back rank after Queen E4 take um
would you like me to be Alejandro for a
bit
um
I swear I saw a move here but now I I
can't here is uh wondering if he you
want the answer
um
not really
it's a pride the pride of the chess
player
uh I actually don't say it I want to
calculate too I know I want to cook
that is not really working at the moment
um
all right Peter gone uh instead of
Bishop C8 Bishop C6 is winning Bishop C8
actually is not great you should not be
doing this bishop C6 here yeah Bishop
six does win though
ah you cannot take us neither three
characters and Rook B8 doesn't exist I
think stopping Rook B8 is incredibly
important
yeah
yeah I'll just
um I'll just assume that I would have
found this yes good assumption and you
get to eventually
play this end game out Knight F3 check
the game Transformers a little bit
Bishop E2 was actually a very good move
Knight takes Bishop takes Rooks C8
you're a little bit down on time here
you see the second stick down how sure
are you that you're going to convert
this oh I was like 70 sure it's a draw
okay
um
I I thought that maybe like my my queen
D4 decision wasn't the best but on the
other hand I I was low on time and
if he goes to Queen F2 and I get pushed
back and then his piece is coming like
he's not down that much material right
so I thought I would take the safe Edge
rather than go for some total mess but I
I thought that this is a very Druid
ending uh there are a couple of critical
moments that I want to ask you about
specifically here why can D4 I mean
after like we were repeating why did he
decide to do something else
I mean I would have played another move
after Bishop D4 besides Bishop A2 but
but I didn't see the move
um I didn't see how to improve my
position after Bishop D4
so I was very happy with King Depot
before because then at least like I can
play H5 and he has to think about how to
like he he has so many approaches to
after H5 I mean there should be a draw
but he has a tough choice because
everything looks playable
uh we had this position here after check
on D3 King C4 you spent still a lot of
time in this in this decision between
taking on C5 and I assume playing D5
yeah I checked out I was like D5 should
be critical but his C Pawn starts to run
like King B5 and okay I thought I had
two choices Rook B3 or let's say take I
mean Rook V3 is also C6
um yeah if Rook C3 the problem is Bishop
C5 King d8 and his Bishop goes to f8
when I saw this I started to get kind of
scared because of this colorful okay and
then I realized that he has more than
one past one so I guess check uh check
where after C6 probably Rook B3 check is
is crucial King A6
yeah uh King B7
I assume
um Bishop Ford c7d
C7 and like King D7 or D4 first step I
think 87 first no maybe it doesn't make
a difference yeah check let's say can be
a king to someone yeah
yeah I I don't I saw something like
Bishop D1 and got scared in this
position but Bishop A4 right but maybe
there's like Bishop C2 here I don't know
but this was very hard to visualize uh
such a
I mean
I thought the other one is like a safe
try and this one five minutes left I I
really didn't think I would be able to
keep control uh and he was blitzing I
like I knew that he wasn't
like calculating things he was just
trying to like semi-bluff me right but
uh but it kind of worked I guess this
was the critical way to play but I just
couldn't bring myself to do it now you
mentioned that he was blitzing he was
trying to Bluff you when did you feel
that he finally let his guard down and
you were able to take this one home well
at some point I got this F5 Pawn like
after I was surprised when he played
Bishop B4
although I thought he'd already gone to
very oh wait oh so the first thing is
after king of seven Bishop D4 I thought
he rushed with this it wasn't there
Bishop F3 here yeah that's immediately
yeah I just uh I was ready for the draw
and and then he played Bishop before I
was like so thankful for this gift
because now he he's in a very unpleasant
situation his King is in a in a very
awkward place he can't get it to the
king side where it needs to be and um
and then I thought Bishop B4 was also
like after that I I do win his his F
Pawn right um
but not the game necessarily yeah maybe
you would still draw but suddenly white
has to to find some very difficult
um path to dry thought I think we've got
all the way here and I think the
decisive mistake was finally with Bishop
C7 so so this is still dry E4 apparently
it still keeps I thought the king H7
Fall by G5 I would like have
I think we analyzed this in the
broadcast
uh King H7 and we decided that
we went to the play five I don't know if
it works but we wanted to please by the
way E5 I thought so Rook A4 King E3
uh do you put the bishop on G5 you just
put the bishop on G5 really that's a
draw that's a draw yes oh okay yeah I
like saw this line take and take on H4
and Bishop G7 and and then uh I thought
I would win that
um
or
no I mean thank you yeah she said I was
like looking at this position but I
didn't consider Bishop G5 but I really
was down to like my last minute for
these moves so right that's very true
um you play Rook C5 and it feel it felt
that the game just yeah this king is so
cut off that's the problem for him and
uh it didn't feel like I really like I
had a wealth of choice to win I thought
like F5 is probably the easiest but G
optional so you're winning
absolutely yeah let me just check real
quick uh how this game is going feels
like we have plenty to analyze there uh
E6 actually kind of a crucial moment
linear with one minute right how is this
not dead for black
it might be I don't know I decided uh
he's collecting all the pawns though
Queen G6 Queen H6 or yeah Queen F6 uh
after King f8
where do you go G8 I guess yeah and
in G7 or something yeah
okay so you can collect H5 if you want
with check right
I don't know about you with check but
you kind of collect it no I mean like
with this check oh yeah yeah
I think your feet I suppose yeah and
then just take but then but you can also
no you should do this yeah so where does
it can go to G8 I guess G8 or f8 yeah
we're already all the way down to Queen
takes E6 we're taking G7 but it's not
force of course yeah king of Fate is
probably the same the same the same
thing yeah
so I think Lanier a huge favorite to win
this one we might have a four decisive
game around again what is that what do
you have to collect H5 because black
puts a queen on
I guess a 29 I mean Three Palms
the passbone here on the B5 you play
Queen F4 and then you push well White's
Queen is a little bit awkwardly placed
somehow I'm getting ghosts of this uh
end game of Lanier against Levon in the
American Cup I also had to design a game
against linear like this a very similar
one to this where he had like one pass
pawn and I had three pass pawns with
queens and it was it was winning what we
eventually Drew and this was in the year
like 2010 or something something like
that some time ago yeah
Bobby
this one is over what's next for you
uh the well there's some online stuff
like there's this Global Championship
that uh
has now a sort of on everyone's radar
and uh the next uh well then there's
also chess 960
um Championship after this which will
which we'll play yeah and um
and then there's a US championship and
that's pretty much all on my calendar
for for this year oh it's a busy year uh
overall but nice to have a couple of
months break at the end yeah
I mean who knows like I might end up
playing some
event that I don't know about yet you
came up with a podcast recently with our
friend Christian carilla tell us a
little bit about that initiative yeah
that was uh he came to me with idea I
thought it would be interesting and fun
it's uh it's an enormous amount of work
um
and
yeah we're still starting out we're
still trying to learn the ropes but it's
been fun I'll let you plug it in you can
say the name of the podcast it's called
the c squared podcast and um and you can
find it on yeah we have it on YouTube
Spotify
um Apple music and
other places too I'm not exactly sure a
great plug there well thank you Bobby
for joining us in this interview
congratulations on finishing the
tournament and the grand chess Tour on a
high note thank you
yes uh let's uh let us do the same uh
Fabi it's always nice as Peter was
mentioning uh to finish such a
tournament with a victory